This is 99% invisible. I'm Katie Mingle filling in for Roman Mars. In the early morning of September 20th, 2017, a category for Hurricane hit the island of Puerto Rico. Hurricane Maria slamming into the island and as you heard, one official saying the island is destroyed. The first category for storm, District, Puerto Rico, in 85 years, power lines are down. Streets are impossible. Many roads are flooded. Maria was a beast of a hurricane.
这里是 99% Invisible。我是凯蒂·明格尔，替罗曼·马尔斯主持。2017年9月20日清晨，一个四级飓风袭击了波多黎各岛。飓风“玛丽亚”猛烈冲击着这座岛屿，正如你所听到的，一位官员称这座岛屿已经被毁。85年来袭击波多黎各的首个四级风暴，电线倒塌。街道无法通行。许多道路被洪水淹没。“玛丽亚”简直是一头暴戾的飓风。
The strongest one to hit the island since 1932. The wind was blowing 155 miles an hour, which is very close to being a category five. And it didn't just hit one stretch of the coast. It actually moved across the whole island, ripping up everything in its path. You know, brush everywhere, trees down, power lines down, obviously everywhere,
这是自1932年以来袭击该岛最强的一次。风速达到每小时155英里，非常接近五级飓风。而且它不只是袭击了海岸的一段。它实际上横扫了整座岛屿，将沿途的一切都撕得粉碎。你知道，到处都是灌木丛，树木倒塌，电线倒塌，显而易见，到处都是，
you know, the entire island in the dark. That's Danielle Ellercone. He spent some time reporting in Puerto Rico after the storm and wrote an article about it for Wired magazine. The next morning people wake up, they go out of their houses, their apartments, and they look out on the streets to survey the damage
你知道，整个岛屿陷入黑暗。那是丹尼尔·阿莱尔孔。风暴过后，他在波多黎各进行了段时间的报道，并为《连线》杂志写了一篇关于此事的文章。第二天早上，人们醒来，走出房屋、公寓，眺望街道以评估损失，
and start trying to make sense of what they're seeing in front of them, you know? And one of the people out there that day, driving around in a state of utter shock, was a guy named Jorge Brasero. That's from a video that Jorge took the day after the storm. He's from the capital city of San Juan and he told me he was just totally caught off guard by how bad this storm was. It really became obviously known for everybody around that we were in deep trouble. But it wasn't for a few days when Jorge actually
并开始试图理解眼前所见的一切，你知道吗？那天在外面的人之一、一个处于极度震惊中开车四处查看的人，是一个叫豪尔赫·布拉塞罗的家伙。那是豪尔赫在风暴过后拍的一段视频中的画面。他来自首都圣胡安，他告诉我，这场风暴如此糟糕，完全出乎他的意料。我们陷入了大麻烦，这显然成了周围每个人都知道的事。但直到几天后，豪尔赫
made it into work that he fully grasped the scale of the crisis. He works at Prepo, which stands for Puerto Rican Electric Power Authority. It's the public utility that provides electricity for nearly the entire island. I actually arrive at the power plant. I notice that I was one of the few that actually made it because most people live inland. When he gets there, he makes his way over to this big computer screen that shows the outline of Puerto Rico and inside of that a bunch of lines, kind of like a big connect to the dots with each line representing a power line. And every blinking line, it means a down power line. And the whole island was blinking. Every single line was down. Every single line in the island was down and that had never happened before.
真正去上班时，他才完全理解了这场危机的规模。他在普雷帕工作，也就是波多黎各电力局的缩写。它是为几乎整个岛屿提供电力的公用事业公司。我实际上到达了发电厂。我注意到我是少数几个真正到达这里的人之一，因为大多数人都住在内陆。当他到达那里时，他走到一个大电脑屏幕前，屏幕上显示着波多黎各的轮廓，里面有一堆线条，有点像一个巨大的连点游戏，每条线代表一条输电线路。每条闪烁的线都意味着一条倒塌的输电线路。整个岛屿都在闪烁。每一条线都倒塌了。岛上的每一条线都倒塌了，这以前从未发生过。
The trajectory of Maria was almost as if it had been designed by an evil genius. The way it cut across the island was such that it essentially struck every major transmission line. The scale of the destruction to the power grid was hard even for Jorge Bracero to comprehend, and he knew that day that he would spend the next several months helping Puerto Rico recover through his work with Prepa. What he didn't know yet was that thousands of people would come to count on him, specifically him, to help them get through their year in the dark. Jorge Bracerro is one of those people who you can tell you're going to like just spicing a picture of him.
“玛丽亚”的轨迹几乎就像是一个邪恶天才的设计。它横穿全岛的方式，使其基本上击中了每一条主要的输电线。电网遭受破坏的规模，甚至连豪尔赫·布拉塞罗都很难理解，他那天就知道，他将在接下来的几个月里，通过在普雷帕的工作帮助波多黎各恢复。他还不知道的是，成千上万的人会指望他，专门指望他，来帮助他们度过黑暗的一年。豪尔赫·布拉塞罗就是那种你只要看一眼他的照片就知道你会喜欢的人。
He's in his late thirties with short brown hair and a beard and he just looks like a nice guy. I think it's something about his eyes. Daniel Alercone describes him as the light-filling nerdy. He's a guy who will sit and explain to you how an electrical grade works, you know, like, and continue to explain it in my new detail even after it's clear that you like can no longer understand what he's talking about. Jorge has worked for Prepa for 13 years and his job there is a grueling one. He's responsible for operating two 15 story tall boilers. These boilers are heated by 20 giant burners that Jorge also looks after.
他三十多岁，留着短棕色头发和胡须，看起来就是个好人。我觉得是他的眼睛透着某种特质。丹尼尔·阿莱尔孔形容他是“充满光明的书呆子”。他会坐下来向你解释电网是如何运作的，你知道的，并且会继续用极其微小的细节向你解释，即使已经很清楚你再也听不懂他在说什么了。豪尔赫在普雷帕工作了13年，他在那里的工作非常艰苦。他负责操作两座15层楼高的锅炉。这些锅炉由20个巨型燃烧器加热，豪尔赫也负责照看这些燃烧器。
And so he's constantly hiking up and down these stairs that service the different parts of this massively tall equipment. It's extremely hot, you know, every day you're just smelling of petrol and diesel and it's extremely exhaust and sometimes you just hate it. When Maria hit Jorge and his wife Charlotte rode out the storm at her family's house. They weren't hurt, but they were surrounded by devastation. And they found out some really sad news. Charlotte's best friend, who was pregnant, had gone into stress-induced early labor the day the storm hit and lost the baby. This was particularly frightening to them because Charlotte was also pregnant. It was the most tense I've ever been in my life.
因此，他经常要爬上爬下这些服务于这套极其高大的设备不同部分的楼梯。这里非常热，你知道的，每天你闻到的都是汽油和柴油的味道，极其疲惫，有时你简直恨透了。当“玛丽亚”袭来时，豪尔赫和他的妻子夏洛特在她家人的房子里度过了风暴。他们没有受伤，但周围是一片废墟。他们发现了一些非常悲伤的消息。夏洛特的最好朋友怀孕了，在风暴袭击的那天因压力过大而提前分娩，并失去了孩子。这让他们感到格外害怕，因为夏洛特也怀孕了。那是我一生中最紧张的时刻。
What if Charlotte also went into early labor? Or what if the baby was born but couldn't survive the post-Maria world with no electricity and temperatures routinely in the 90s. Because when you sleep at night, that heat was so unbearable. I'm serious. The amount of heat in the air was so brutal that you would think, you know, I'm just going to get naked outside because I can't contain the stem heat. So I'm thinking, a newborn can't survive this.
如果夏洛特也提前分娩了怎么办？或者如果孩子生下来了，却无法在后“玛丽亚”时代的世界中生存下来——那里没有电力，气温经常高达90多华氏度。因为当你夜间睡觉时，那种热度是如此难以忍受。我是说，空气中的热量是如此残酷，以至于你会想，你知道的，我干脆赤身裸体走到外面去算了，因为我无法忍受这闷热。所以我心想，新生儿根本无法在这样的环境中生存。
Jorge even considered trying to get his wife off the island. But eight months pregnant, they don't allow you to fly. After the storm, Jorge and Charlotte bounced from place to place, staying with friends who had generators. At home, Jorge fredded over his wife and the baby who was coming, ready or not in November. At work, things were even more stressful. The first priority was to get power to hospitals and water treatment plants.
豪尔赫甚至考虑过设法送妻子离开小岛。但怀孕八个月是不被允许坐飞机的。风暴过后，豪尔赫和夏洛特从一个地方辗转到另一个地方，寄宿在有发电机的有缘人家里。在家时，豪尔赫为妻子和即将于11月无论如何都要出生的孩子感到焦虑。在工作时，情况则更加紧张。首要任务是恢复医院和水处理厂的供电。
Jorge's power plant was one of seven major plants on the island, but all of the others were down, and without those to help, he's kept crashing. Over and over again, because, know they they it would connect as many hospitals as we can but it just wouldn't hold it. Jorge described this like a tug of war. The power plants are on one side and they're giants, but the consumers are on the other side and they pull hard. If one power plant goes down the others will have to work harder and they get tired, sometimes to the point of collapse. After Maria, there was only one giant power plant
豪尔赫的发电厂是岛上的七大电厂之一，但其他所有电厂都瘫痪了，没有它们的协助，他的电厂不断崩溃。一次又一次，因为，你知道的，他们会尽可能多地连接医院，但就是无法维持。豪尔赫将此形容为一场拔河比赛。发电厂在一边，它们是庞然大物，但消费者在另一边，他们拼命拉扯。如果一个发电厂倒下，其他的就必须更努力地工作，它们会感到疲惫，有时甚至会累到崩溃。在“玛丽亚”之后，绳子豪尔赫这一端
on Jorge's side of the rope, and on the other side, hospitals and water treatment plants, which were pulling like crazy. Every time there's a collapse, you have to reboot everything again. Eight hours of work just went down the drain and you have to restart from step one. With just one plant that was constantly collapsing, they had to triage.
只有一个巨型发电厂，而在另一端，医院和水处理厂正疯狂地拉扯。每次发生崩溃，你都必须重新启动所有东西。八小时的工作付诸东流，你不得不从第一步重新开始。只有一座不断崩溃的电厂，他们必须进行分类处理。
It is like I only have one power plant that just got fired up, and I only have enough power for one of those two hospitals right there. Out in the field things weren't any better. Lines were down all over the island, and there weren't nearly enough workers to fix them. Eventually support would arrive from the U.S. mainland, but for the first week or so, Puerto Ricans were basically on their own. You know, we only had 230 power brigades.
这就好比我只有一个刚刚启动的发电厂，而我的电力只够供应眼前这两家医院中的一家。实地的情况也好不到哪里去。全岛到处都在断电，修复电线的工人远远不够。最终，美国本土会派来支援，但在最初的一周左右，波多黎各人基本上只能靠自己。你知道，我们只有230个电力抢修队。
That's all we have for the company for the island. And that is not enough. That is just not enough. There are about three workers in a brigade, so that's 690 people give or take. As a point of comparison, as Florida prepared for Irma, they had 16,000 workers on call. But for anyone paying attention, it was no surprise that Prepa did not have the resources to respond to this disaster. Again, here's Danielle Ellercone.
这就是公司为全岛拥有的全部力量。这还远远不够。这根本不够。一个抢修队大约有三名工人，所以大概有690人左右。作为对比，当佛罗里达州为“厄玛”做准备时，他们有16,000名待命工人。但对于任何留心的人来说，普雷帕没有资源应对这场灾难并不令人意外。再次有请丹尼尔·阿莱尔孔。
Before Maria, the island was in a terrible economic state, a decade or more of economic stagnation. Puerto Rico, a US territory and popular getaway destination, is trying to avoid a default on its staggering debt. It would be the largest. In the decades before Maria, businesses had left the island in droves as the US government phased out a
在“玛丽亚”到来之前，该岛的经济状况糟糕透顶，经历了十年或更长时间的经济停滞。波多黎各作为美国的领地和热门度假胜地，正试图避免其惊人的债务出现违约。这将是最大的一次。在“玛丽亚”爆发前的几十年里，随着美国政府逐步取消了一
series of tax breaks. To make up for all the lost revenue, the Puerto Rican government began borrowing money in the form of bonds. Year after year, issuing more and more bonds, kind of hoping things would turn around, but things did not turn around. By the time Maria hit, the government was in the middle of an enormous debt crisis. And in the course of that prepa was not spared and prepa is saddled over the course of many, many years with a lot of debt, nine billion dollars in debt. Or I could know, it could have,
系列税收减免优惠，企业纷纷撤离该岛。为了弥补所有损失的税收收入，波多黎各政府开始以债券的形式借钱。年复一年，发行越来越多的债券，有点希望情况能有所转机，但情况并没有好转。当“玛丽亚”袭来时，政府正深陷巨大的债务危机之中。在此过程中，普雷帕也未能幸免，普雷帕在多年积聚中背负了大量债务，高达90亿美元的债务。或者我可能知道，它可能有，
no, that sounds like a lot. Can I look at my article? Sure, yeah. Because I'm not sure. Daniel actually had to stop and check his notes while we were talking to make sure this was right. Wow. Yeah, I know, that's it. That's it. That's insane. Because of cost and because of debt, they're constantly postponing maintenance. Like, for example, in the mainland US, the vegetation is kept mode so that there's
不，这听起来像是一大笔钱。我能看看我的文章吗？当然，可以。因为我不确定。丹尼尔在交谈时实际上不得不停下来核对他的笔记，以确保这是对的。哇。是的，我知道，就是这样。就是这样。这太疯狂了。由于成本和债务原因，他们不断推迟维护工作。比如，在美国本土，植被会被修剪，这样就
basically a road that runs underneath the power lines. That's called right of way right and you're supposed to maintain the right of way to make it easy in in the case of you know some disaster to access the fallen towers right so in Puerto Rico that doesn't that doesn't exist. When Maria hit, Prepa had been limping along. Now they would have to deal with one of the biggest crises the island had ever faced. But there was another problem and it was a big one. They basically had no strategy for communicating with the public. They didn't have a presence on Twitter or Facebook. The Twitter feed was all but dead. The Facebook page was nonexistent. There was no communication saying to the people
基本上在电线下方有一条通道。这叫做通行权，对吧？你应该维护通行权，以便在发生某种灾难时能够轻松进入倒塌的塔架，对吧？所以在波多黎各，这并不存在。当“玛丽亚”袭来时，普雷帕一直步履维艰。现在他们不得不应对该岛有史以来面临的最大危机之一。但还有另一个问题，而且是个大问题。他们基本上没有与公众沟通的策略。他们在推特或脸书上没有存在感。推特动态几乎处于停滞状态。脸书页面根本不存在。没有任何沟通告诉人们
where the brigades were working. Everything was kept hushed, just to prevent conflict. And with little actual information from Prepa, TV news stations just kind of made stuff up, which made Jorge want to throw his television across the room. There was a political analyst and he was saying what he was saying was wrong, first completely wrong, and not only that, he was inciting more fear and desperation rather than comfort. And I spent that night just screaming at the TV,
抢修队在哪里工作。一切都被秘而不宣，只是为了防止冲突。由于普雷帕几乎没有提供实际信息，电视新闻台只能凭空捏造，这让豪尔赫恨不得把电视机砸到房间另一头。当时有一位政治分析师，他说的那些话全都是错的，首先是彻底的大错特错，不仅如此，他没有带来安慰，反而煽动了更多的恐惧和绝望。那个晚上我一直在对着电视尖叫，
my family was, you know, just trailing me to be quiet. But that action right there is basically what, you know, it just gave me an epiphany. He felt like people need to hear what's really happening. I decided to become the news outlet. Jorge starts this one-man campaign to educate Puerto Rican about electrical power. He'd do it on his Facebook page and he wouldn't ask for permission.
我的家人，你知道的，一直在劝我安静点。但正是那个举动，基本上给了我一个顿悟。他觉得人们需要听到真实发生的事情。我决定成为新闻媒体。豪尔赫开始了这场单枪匹马的运动，向波多黎各人普及电力知识。他在自己的脸书页面上这样做，而且他不会征求许可。
Update October 30. Re-share please spread the knowledge. Unit 9 out because of broken boiler it will take days to repair. It wasn't 40 megawatts. So early on, Jorge's posts are very technical and very specific. And at eight, start at relay tests. Everything will be good to turn it on and get ready. Such and such per gate will be at such and such line, you know, working to restore such and such wattage, to such and such neighborhood. That information was basically for company use.
10月30日更新。请转发，传播知识。9号机组因锅炉损坏停机，需要几天时间修复。这不是40兆瓦。所以早期的时候，豪尔赫的帖子非常技术化，也非常具体。8点开始继电器测试。一切准备就绪，可以开机并做好准备。某某抢修队将在某某线路，你知道的，努力恢复某某瓦特的电力，供应给某某社区。这些信息基本上是供公司内部使用的。
So I decided to start leaking that information to the public. Every night Jorge would come home from a 16-hour shift at work, hanging his smelly clothes out on the porch and start writing. Update, October 31. In a 5 and 6, 95 and 9. I was spending around four hours just writing and calling friends on the field and asking them to validate the information. I never revealed any sources that I had because I was afraid for any backlash that they would get. After he gathered all the information from his sources in the field,
所以我决定开始向公众泄露这些信息。每天晚上，豪尔赫结束16小时的工作回到家，把发臭的衣服挂在门廊上，然后开始写作。10月31日更新。5号机组和6号机组，95号和9号。我花大约四个小时写文章，给现场的朋友打电话，请他们验证信息。我从未透露过我的任何消息来源，因为我担心他们会遭到报复。在收集了来自现场消息来源的所有信息后，
Jorge would type out these extremely long posts. Sometimes a thousand words or more with his thumbs on an iPhone. Update. November 3rd. Current demand, 993 megawatts. Cell service was so spotty that sometimes he'd have to drive to find a signal. His wife, Charlotte, who was still pregnant, would be like, what are you doing? My wife would be angry. But then something happened. People started responding.
豪尔赫会用iPhone的大拇指敲出这些极长的帖子。有时一千字甚至更多。11月3日更新。当前需求量，993兆瓦。手机信号非常不稳定，有时他不得不开车去找信号。他的妻子夏洛特当时还怀着孕，会问：“你在干什么？”我妻子会生气的。但随后发生了事情。人们开始作出回应。
More and more people started sharing Jorge's posts. Posts of his were getting thousands of reposts and hundreds and hundreds of comments. And he switched at a certain point from a personal page to like a fan page. That was my wife's idea. She realized that it was big. And it was important, so I decided to post every day.
越来越多的人开始分享豪尔赫的帖子。他的帖子获得了数千次转发以及成百上千条评论。在某个时间点，他将个人页面切换成了粉丝页面。那是主意我妻子的主意。她意识到这影响很大，而且很重要，所以我决定每天都发帖。
Update November 4th. Jorge wanted to give people information, and it was important so I decided to post every day. Update November 4th. Jorge wanted to give people information, but he also wanted to show them that people were actually out there working on getting their power back. It was just a really difficult problem to fix. There's a basic problem to the grid, which is the majority of the population lives in the north.
11月4日更新。豪尔赫想给人们提供信息，这很重要，所以我决定每天发帖。11月4日更新。豪尔赫想给人们提供信息，但他也想向他们展示，确实有人在外面努力恢复电力。这只是一个非常难解决的问题。电网存在一个根本问题，那就是绝大多数人口都住在北部。
So imagine like a rectangle. Across the middle is a mountain range, and the majority of the population lives above that mountain range, and the majority of the power is below that mountain range. And servicing the towers in the mountains was not easy. That involves, in some cases, you know, flying a tower in by a helicopter and then dropping it in and then guys hiking in and trying to set it up. On top of the difficulty of the work, Prepa just didn't have the supplies it needed.
所以想象一个长方形。中间横贯着一条山脉，绝大多数人口生活在那条山脉的上方，而绝大部分电力来自那条山脉的下方。维护山区中的铁塔并不容易。在某些情况下，这意味着，你知道的，用直升机把铁塔运进来，然后将其放下，接着由工人徒步进入并试图将其组装起来。除了工作本身的难度之外，普雷帕根本没有所需的物资。
Remember, Marie was the third in a series of devastating hurricanes that season. We're live here in Houston where Harvey's reigns keep coming. The sun returned here today and revealed the devastation left by Irma. The once powerful hurricane... This hurricane triple whammy meant that all the things Puerto Rico needed were in high demand in other places. So we had no materials, no anything. Like basic stuff. Like supplies of like not having enough nuts and bolts.
记住，“玛丽亚”是那个季节一系列毁灭性飓风中的第三个。我们在休斯顿进行现场直播，这里的哈维暴雨还在继续。太阳今天在这里重现，显露出了欧玛留下的满目疮痍。曾经威力强大的飓风……这三重飓风连击意味着波多黎各所需的所有物资在其他地方都极度短缺。所以我们没有任何材料，什么都没有。就像基础的东西一样。比如物资紧缺，甚至没有足够的螺母和螺栓。
You know? Screws. You know, I met guys who were finding stuff in the grass and they were like, huh, can I use this? And this stuff is like 60 years old. As prepaid did the slow work of restoring electricity, Puerto Ricans who could afford them relied on generators for power. There were so many that the noise of them
你知道吗？螺丝。你知道的，我遇到过一些人在草丛里捡东西，他们会问，呃，我能用这个吗？而这些东西已经有60年历史了。随着普雷帕缓慢地进行电力恢复工作，买得起发电机的波多黎各人依靠发电机来获取电力。发电机实在是太多了，以至于它们的噪音
drowned out the natural sounds of the island. The sound of the cookie, cookie, cookie, cookie cookie cookie like that sound I'd been replaced by the sound of like mrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrr post after post on Facebook, Jorge did his best to explain why things were moving so slowly. You need 8, 10 megawatts on one of my own. And I think he did a good job at that critical moment of trying to explain to people, you know, this is the reality of the grid that we have, a grid that was flawed even before Maria came and and and wrecked it. But if you scroll through Jorge's posts, you'll see that they aren't just technical information. He's also encouraging people to be their best selves and look out for each other.
掩盖了小岛大自然的声音。诸如小鸟的叫声之类的声音，已经被……这样的声音所取代。在脸书上的一篇又一篇帖子里，豪尔赫尽最大努力解释为什么进展如此缓慢。我的一台发电机上需要8到10兆瓦的电力。我认为他在那个关键时刻做得很好，试图向人们解释，你知道的，这就是我们拥有的电网的现实，一个甚至在“玛丽亚”到来并摧毁它之前就存在缺陷的电网。但如果你浏览豪尔赫的帖子，你会发现它们不仅仅是技术信息。他还鼓励人们展现最好的一面，并守望相助。
All I'm thinking is like, do you imagine if you had one community that has power and the community next to it does not, how that people are going to start, you know, lashing out and start feeling resentment and jealousy, there's going to be riots in the streets. Where can you, can you read one of these little pep talks that you wrote? I'm here. I'm going to send you one on the center. Katie Mingle. Yeah. Let me just click to open.orregido? Sí, sí. ¡Te he recorregido! Sí, así que si te recorregues, a través de la primera enpanes y entonces,
我满脑子想的就是，你想象一下，如果你有一个社区有电，而它隔壁的社区没有电，人们会开始作何感想，你知道的，他们会开始发泄怨恨和嫉妒，街头将会发生暴乱。你能不能，你能不能读一下你写的这些鼓舞人心的话中的一则？我在。我这就发给你一个。凯蒂·明格尔。好的。让我点开看看。正确了吗？是的，是的。我纠正了你！是的，所以如果你纠正了自己，通过第一批停电，然后，
tú puedes decirles lo que significa en inglés. Sí, esa es... Sé que a lo mejor a tu lado está oscuro. Va a aprender. Si ya está aprendido, ayuda a los apagados. Mirar las áreas. Da de tilo mejor que pueda. Ayer, cocinas y la barropa de los vecinos. No he estado olvidado, no está solo. Este momento va a pasar.
你可以告诉他们这意味着什么英文。是的，那是……我知道也许你身边是一片黑暗。电力将会恢复。如果已经通电了，去帮助那些断电的人。环顾四周。尽你所能做到最好。帮邻居做冰块、做饭和洗衣服。你没有被遗忘，你并不孤单。这个时刻终将过去。
¿Qué es eso? Yo sé que el próximo a ustedes es en la darkness. Es que se va a dar un litro. Si tú estás parecido, te ayudas a ver las cosas. Si tú estás parecido, te ayudas a ver las cosas. Si tú estás parecido, te ayudas a ver las cosas.
那是什么？我知道你们旁边是一片黑暗。光明将会到来。如果你已经通电了，去帮助需要帮助的人。尽你所能做到最好。制作冰块，做饭，清洗他们的衣服。你没有被遗忘。你绝不孤单。这个时刻将会过去。
Si tú estás parecido, te ayudas a ver las cosas. Si tú estás parecido, te ayudas a ver las cosas. Si tú estás parecido, te ayudas a ver las cosas. What it says is, I know that next to you everything is in darkness. It's going to light up. If you're already powered up, help the ones in need. Do the best thing that you can. Make ice, cook, clean their clothes. You are not forgotten. You are never alone. This moment will pass.
那是什么？我知道你们旁边是一片黑暗。光明将会到来。如果你已经通电了，去帮助需要帮助的人。尽你所能做到最好。制作冰块，做饭，清洗他们的衣服。你没有被遗忘。你绝不孤单。这个时刻将会过去。它的意思是：我知道你们身边的一切都陷入黑暗。光明将会到来。如果你已经通电了，去帮助需要帮助的人。尽你所能做到最好。制作冰块，做饭，清洗他们的衣服。你没有被遗忘。你绝不孤单。这个时刻终将过去。
That's what it is. He just brought back a lot of memories. Over time, where his post earned him a kind of celebrity status on the island. I went to go see a comedy show and he was mentioned in the comedy show and everyone cracked up. Like an entire theater, like hundreds of people, these howls of recognition and like applause and people doubled over laughing because it seemed like everybody was checking every day
就是这样。这勾起了很多回忆。随着时间的推移，豪尔赫的帖子为他在岛上赢得了某种名人般的地位。我去看了一场喜剧演出，演出中提到了他，每个人都笑得前仰后合。就像整个剧院，成百上千的人，发出识别出共鸣的欢呼声和掌声，人们笑得直不起腰来，因为似乎每个人每天都在查看
what Jorge Brasero was saying. At the first time in my life that I became a meme. One Jorge meme was an image of his face on one of those Latin prayer candles. They would say, don't let this candle burn out if you want power. Another meme referred to him as Saint Beard. I had a very, very rough beard. It wasn't trimmed down, so they started calling me St. Beard.
豪尔赫·布拉塞罗说了什么。我这辈子第一次成了表情包。其中一个豪尔赫表情包是他的脸被印在那些拉丁祈祷蜡烛上。上面写着：如果你想要电，就不要让这根蜡烛熄灭。另一个表情包称他为“圣胡须”。我留着非常非常粗糙的胡须。没有修剪过，所以他们开始叫我圣胡须。
You know, this car is his beard if you want power. By this point, Jorge's boss is new what he was doing, and whether they approved or not, they sort of had to go along because the public was on his side. People were stopping him in the streets to thank him, and when they do see me on the street, you know, they give me a hug because I'm not, I'm not usually a hand-checked guy. I'm more of a hug guy.
你知道的，如果你想要电，这就是圣胡须。到了这个时候，豪尔赫的老板们都知道他在做什么，无论他们是否批准，他们都不得不顺其自然，因为公众站在他这一边。人们在街上拦住他向他道谢，当他们在街上看到我时，你知道的，他们会给我一个拥抱，因为我不是，我通常不是那种握手的人。我更喜欢拥抱。
On November 14th, 2017, Jorge's baby was born, a healthy baby girl who they named Lea. Amazingly Charlotte's mom and dad had just gotten power the day before. So when they left the hospital, the family went straight to her parents' air conditioned house with their new baby girl. This was the first Christmas in Puerto Rico since Hurricane Maria devastated the island, local engineers at the time. By Christmas about half of the island had had their power restored. But the mood was grim.
2017年11月14日，豪尔赫的孩子出生了，是个健康的女儿，他们给她取名叫莉亚。神奇的是，夏洛特的父母在前一天刚刚恢复了供电。因此，当他们离开医院时，一家人带着他们的新生女儿直接去了她父母开着空调的房子。这是自飓风“玛丽亚”摧毁该岛以来波多黎各过的第一个圣诞节，当时的当地工程师。到圣诞节时，大约半数岛屿的电力已经恢复。但气氛依然沉重。
So many people had lost friends or relatives or had their homes destroyed in the storm. Many people were still in the dark, and no one felt much like celebrating. Still, there were moments of likeness. A local musician had rewritten the song All I Want for Christmas so that instead of All I Want for Christmas is you, It says all I want for Christmas is loose, which means light in Spanish. One line in the rewritten song even name drops Jorge pleading in Spanish. Jorge Bracero, please give me what I want. Okay, I'm sending you this song that you posted on Facebook, do you see it? Oh my God, you have the video of me singing.
许多人在风暴中失去了朋友、亲戚，或者家园被毁。许多人仍然生活在黑暗中，没有人觉得有什么值得庆祝的。不过，也有一些轻松的时刻。一位当地音乐家重写了歌曲《圣诞节我想要的一切》（All I Want for Christmas），因此歌词不再是“圣诞节我想要的就是你”，而是变成了“圣诞节我想要的只是luz”，在西班牙语中是“光”的意思。重写歌曲中的一句甚至点名了豪尔赫，用西班牙语恳求道：“豪尔赫·布拉塞罗，请给我想要的。”好的，我正在发送你发在脸书上的这首歌，你看到了吗？哦天哪，你有我唱歌的视频。
Ha ha ha ha ha. I just want to say something. Eventually, the woman who wrote the parody song reached out to Jorge, and they made a video of the two of them singing it together. To the look it oh Oh yeah this is great. I'm gonna watch this again later on. I forgot, I almost forget about this.
哈哈哈。我只想说一件事。最终，创作这首恶搞歌曲的女性联系了豪尔赫，他们制作了一个两人一起合唱这首歌的视频。快看，哦。哦，是的，这太棒了。我一会儿再看这个。我忘了，我差点把这事给忘了。
By spring, around 85% of the island had power. Still, there were thousands of people who didn't. In the spring, I visited a kind of old folks home up in the hills. And at the bottom of the hill, there was power. But there, there was no power. And they just couldn't understand why. And they were just beside themselves and just were desperate and the sense of being forgotten you know. Jorge continued with his daily updates which lines were being fixed where the
到了春季，大约85%的岛屿恢复了电力。尽管如此，仍有数千人没有电。在春天，我访问了山坡上的一家类似老人院的地方。在山脚下，是有电的。但在那里，没有电。他们就是不明白为什么。他们感到不知所措、绝望，有一种被遗忘的感觉，你知道的。豪尔赫继续他的每日更新，包括哪些线路正在修复、抢修队接下来要去哪里。
brigades were headed next. To the team AE brigades and the American contractors. And to keep up a sense of momentum he also shared videos as new places got power like this one where an elementary school in the town of Puerto Nuevo And to keep up a sense of momentum, he also shared videos as new places got power. Like this one, where an elementary school in the town of Puerto Nuevo finally gets electricity. This video is taken on someone's iPhone from the hallway of the school. Kids are running by with their arms in the air going completely bananas. The teachers are jumping up and down.
向AE抢修队和美国承包商致敬。为了保持一种前进的势头，当新的地方通电时，他也分享了视频，比如下面这个位于新港镇的一所小学终于通电了。这个视频是用某人的iPhone从学校走廊拍的。孩子们挥舞着双臂跑过，开心得简直要疯了。老师们激动得上下跳跃。
It's just pure joy. It's so happy to see it that I figured people would be happy to see it too. Every week it seemed a new town was celebrating. I started telling people tape it. Woo! Yeah, gonna lose! A lot of these celebration videos included fireworks, which Jorge said in real life became sort of a beacon. You'd see them from far away and you know.
那真是纯粹的喜悦。看到这一幕是如此开心，我想大家看到它也会很开心。每周似乎都有一个新的城镇在庆祝。我开始告诉人们把它录下来。呜！耶，要摆脱黑暗了！许多这类庆祝视频都包含烟花，豪尔赫说这在现实中变成了一种某种灯塔。你从远处就能看到它们，并且你知道。
That guy just got power right now and this is their celebration. In the comments to these celebration videos, Jorge assured people that soon it would be their turn. Just remember that even if you don't have power right now, you will have it and this is going to be you. if you don't have power right now, you will have it and this is going to be you. Power has now been restored to all of Puerto Rico. It's been nearly 11 months since Hurricane Maria roared ashore and took out the power. Finally in August of 2018, Prepa announced that the entire island had been reconnected to the grid. It was six weeks before the year anniversary of Maria and just in time for the next hurricane season. Preba meanwhile is arguably in a worse place than it was before Maria.
那家伙刚刚通电了，这就是他们的庆祝。在这些庆祝视频的评论中，豪尔赫向人们保证，很快就轮到他们了。只需记住，即使你现在没有电，你也会有的，这就是你们未来的样子。如果你们现在没有电，你们也会有的，这就是你们未来的样子。波多黎各全岛现已恢复供电。距离飓风“玛丽亚”肆虐登陆并摧毁电力系统已经过去近11个月了。最终在2018年8月，普雷帕宣布全岛已重新接入电网。这在“玛丽亚”一周年纪念日前六 weeks，且正赶上下一个飓风季到来之前。与此同时，普雷帕的处境可以说是比“玛丽亚”爆发前还要糟糕。
There's been a lack of steady leadership over the last year with five different directors cycling through the position at the home. One guy lasted, you know, like a day. There was a sense of a rudderless ship, to be honest. A sense of an absolutely rudderless ship. For years, a weird FEMA rule had been in place that recipients of disaster money couldn't replace anything with a different IE,
过去一年缺乏稳定的领导，有五位不同的主任走马灯似地担任过这个职位。有一个家伙，你知道的，只坚持了一天。说实话，有一种群龙无首的感觉。一种绝对群龙无首的感觉。多年来，联邦紧急事务管理局（FEMA）一直存在一条奇怪的规则，即灾难资金的接受者不能用不同的、更昂贵的东西来替换任何东西。
more expensive thing. For example, wooden posts couldn't be replaced with stronger metal posts. So Puerto Ricans didn't actually get the opportunity to improve their infrastructure. It's the same grid they had before with a population that's significantly more vulnerable. And Daniel says this part can't be overstated. Puerto Ricans were traumatized by Maria. It's not just that they went through this storm and then went through the aftermath of
例如，木质电线杆不能更换为更结实的金属电线杆。所以波多黎各人实际上并没有机会改善他们的基础设施。这还是他们以前拥有的那个电网，而人口却变得更加脆弱。丹尼尔说，这部分怎么强调都不过分。波多黎各人被“玛丽亚”创伤了。不仅仅是因为他们经历了这场风暴，然后经历了风暴之后的余波。
the storm. It's, I think, for a lot of people, it's what the aftermath of the storm told them, which is essentially, we don't care about you. You're not, you're forgotten, you don't matter. The depth of this wound is just very, very deep. Now Prepa is in the process of privatizing, basically selling itself off piece by piece in hopes that a private company or various private companies will be able to deliver a better service than the government has.
我认为，对很多人来说，这是风暴的余波告诉他们的事实，那就是基本上：我们不在乎你。你不是，你被遗忘了，你无足轻重。这道伤口的深度实在是太深太深了。现在普雷帕正在进行私有化进程，基本上是一块一块地出售自己，希望一家私营公司或几家私营公司能够提供比政府更好的服务。
But a lot of people are skeptical. Jorge Bracero is still working at PREPA, still doing the hot, exhausting job of maintaining a 15-story boiler. He'd like to stop doing such hard physical labor. He'd like someone to put him in charge of social media or put his other talents to use. I'm up for it, I would love to. But so far, they haven't. Hurricane season wasn't full swing when I talked to Jorge. So of course I asked him how he was feeling about that. When people ask me it's like, are we ready for our next hurricane? I'm like, no. We need a break. It just gave us, I don't know, maybe two years. It just gave us, I don't know, maybe two years. Just gave us that time, that window in which our people can keep working, keep working,
但许多人对此持怀疑态度。豪尔赫·布拉塞罗仍在普雷帕工作，依然从事着维护15层高锅炉的炎热、劳累的工作。他希望不要再做这么重的体力活了。他希望有人能让他负责社交媒体，或者让他的其他才华得以发挥。我愿意，我非常愿意。但到目前为止，他们还没有这么做。当我采访豪尔赫时，飓风季正处于全面进行中。所以我当然问了他对此有何感受。当人们问我时，就像是，“我们准备好迎接下一个飓风了吗？”我说：“不。我们需要休息。”它只是给了我们，我不知道，也许两年时间。它只是给了我们，我不知道，也许两年时间。只是给了我们那段时光，那个窗口期，让我们的员工可以继续工作，继续工作，
keep working so that that system can hold a little longer. Climate change and everything that comes with it is a reality. You know, hurricane seasons are going to get longer. We're going to see more, you know, and that's pretty scary. Jorge told me he thinks Puerto Ricans could survive another hurricane if they had to, another year in the dark even. He wouldn't worry as much about the island evolving into anarchy as he once did.
继续工作，好让那个系统能再撑久一点。气候变化及其带来的一切都是现实。你知道的，飓风季会变得越来越长。我们会看到更多，你知道的，这挺吓人的。豪尔赫告诉我，他认为如果必须的话，波多黎各人能够挺过另一场飓风，甚至再经历一年黑暗的日子。他不再像以前那样担心这座岛屿会陷入无政府状态。
He saw the best of people after Maria, and he thinks they could do it again. Just please, please, not this year. Poor Hey, Bracero was not the only person in Puerto Rico to take matters into their own hands after Maria. All over the island, people were stepping into new roles and figuring out DIY solutions. But one town that Daniel and other corn visited took this really, really far. The people actually said, to hell with waiting on Prepa, we're doing this work ourselves. Daniel will tell us that story after this.
他在“玛丽亚”之后看到了人性最好的一面，他认为他们可以再次做到。只是拜托，拜托，不要是今年。豪尔赫·布拉塞罗并不是“玛丽亚”过后唯一一个亲力亲为的波多黎各人。在全岛各地，人们都在承担新的角色，并摸索DIY解决方案。但丹尼尔和阿莱尔孔访问的一个城镇把这一点做得非常、非常彻底。当地人甚至说：见鬼去吧，不等普雷帕了，我们自己来干。稍后丹尼尔会为我们讲述这个故事。
So it seems like all over Puerto Rico people were kind of taking matters into their own hands. Tell me about this town you went to that basically took it upon themselves to get the lights turned back on. Yeah, absolutely. In this one town called San Sebastien del Pepino, they took a pretty radical step, which is that they took volunteers and sort of made turn them into linemen and created their own kind of unofficial brigade
所以看起来波多黎各各地的人们都在某种程度上亲力亲为。跟我讲讲你去的那个城镇，他们基本上是靠自己把灯重新点亮的。是的，绝对是这样。在一个叫圣塞巴斯蒂安德尔佩皮诺的小镇，他们采取了一个相当激进的步骤，那就是他们招募了志愿者，并把他们变成了电力工人，创建了他们自己某种非官方的抢修队，
to connect and reconnect San Sebastien to the grid. That's amazing. Yeah, the mayor. He's a charming guy with a rhetorical flourish and knows how to give a speech and and make a statement and Basically, he was saying like I had no choice like it was more dangerous to Leave my vulnerable population without electrical power Because a lot of people are older and sick and would have died without
来将圣塞巴斯蒂安重新连接到电网上。太惊人了。是的，市长。他是个很有魅力的人，有着华丽的修辞，懂得如何演讲、如何表明立场，基本上，他当时说的是：我别无选择，让脆弱的人口在没有电力的环境中生活更加危险，因为许多人年老体弱，如果没有
Power they basically got tired of waiting They they started doing the work on their own, which is super dangerous. Like how did they even know how to do it? Like did they did they watch YouTube tutorials or like? Well, so here's the thing. As it happened before the storm, they had bought a couple of decommissioned Prepa trucks with the buckets that rise. They bought them so they could cut brush. The hurricane comes and they're like, well, we've got these trucks. And they had one guy who had worked as a lineman. And another guy who knew a little bit about it, and they'd say, okay, everybody, we need help with
电力就会死去。他们基本上是厌倦了等待。他们开始自己动手干活，这超级危险。就像他们怎么知道该怎么做一样？他们是看YouTube教程还是怎么的？嗯，事情是这样的。就在风暴发生前，他们买了几辆退役的、带有升降斗的普雷帕卡车。他们买这些是为了修剪灌木丛。飓风来了，他们想：好吧，我们有这些卡车。他们有一个人曾当过电力工人。另一个人对这方面略知一二，他们会说：好了，大家，我们需要人帮忙
clearing this brush so we can get to that line, you know, to that electrical pole over there. And then everyone would take out their machetes and help clear the line and they would go and do the work. They had their whole town connected six to eight weeks before the other towns, the other areas around there. Well, and this was just okay. Like they didn't get in trouble. Like did, did Prepa know what they were doing? Prepa had a kind of, you know, they couldn't officially sanction this work.
清理这些灌木丛，这样我们才能靠近那条线路，你知道的，去那边的那根电线杆。然后每个人都会拿出他们的砍刀，帮忙清理线路，然后他们就会去干活。在其他城镇、周边的其他区域通电前6到8周，他们就把整个城镇都连上了电。等等，这真的可以吗？他们没有惹麻烦吗？普雷帕知道他们在做什么吗？普雷帕有一种，你知道的，他们无法官方批准这项工作。
They were certainly coordinating, you know, they had to coordinate, because they couldn't be energizing a line while, you know, Pepino Power Authority guys were connecting it to some polls, you know? So, Pepino Power Authority sounds so official. Was this an official body or is this just a made up name? So, Pipino Power Authority is completely an informal made up thing. Pipino
他们当然在协调，你知道的，他们必须协调，因为他们不能在佩皮诺电力局的人正把线路连接到某些电线杆上时给线路通电，你知道吗？所以，佩皮诺电力局听起来好官方。这是一个官方机构，还是只是一个虚构的名字？所以，佩皮诺电力局完全是一个非正式的虚构名称。佩皮诺
means cucumber in Spanish. I guess it sounds less official when you know it's cucumber. Well, right. And I think that's one of the, I mean, that's where you sort of realized like exactly how savvy, how you're humanists, the mayor is, you know, it's obviously a play on, on Prepa, you know, Puerto Rican electrical power authority, but you know, power authority, you know, it's like, and it's part of, of, of knowing how to, how to tell a story. You know, he got a lot of play for this, and it worked. One of the results is there was a law proposed after all this that was going to loosen the restrictions for mayors
在西班牙语里是黄瓜的意思。我猜当你知道它是黄瓜时，听起来就不那么官方了。嗯，没错。我想这就是其中之一，我的意思是，这就是你开始意识到市长是多么精明、多么有人情味的地方，你知道的，这显然是对普雷帕（波多黎各电力局）的一个谐音梗，你知道的，但是电力局，你知道的，这就像是，这也是如何讲好故事的一部分。你知道的，他为此获得了很高的关注度，而且成功了。其中一个结果是，在此之后提出了一项法律，将放松对市长
and local authorities to do the kind of thing that he did. Just a final note, it actually wasn't a lot that got passed. It was more of an agreement between Prepa and Mayors of cities that basically says, yeah, Mayors can do the work of connecting people to the grid if they want. And Prepa is not responsible if anyone gets hurt. 99% invisible was produced this week by me Katie Mingle and reported by Daniel Allerkone. It was adapted from an article Daniel wrote in Wired magazine called What Happened in the Dark. Mix and Tech Production by Sheree Fusev, Music by Sean Rael. The Laney Hall is the senior editor Kurt Colstet, the digital director.
和地方当局做他那种事情的限制。最后说明一下，实际上通过的并不是一项法律。这更像是普雷帕与各市市长之间的一项协议，基本上规定：是的，如果市长愿意，他们可以做将人们连接到电网的工作。如果有任何人受伤，普雷帕概不负责。本周的《99% Invisible》由我凯蒂·明格尔制作，丹尼尔·阿莱尔孔报道。它改编自丹尼尔在《连线》杂志上写的一篇文章，名为《黑暗中发生了什么》。混音和技术制作由谢里·富瑟夫负责，音乐由肖恩·拉埃尔提供。莱尼·霍尔是高级编辑，柯特·科尔斯特是数字总监。
The rest of the team includes Avery Truffleman, Emmett Fitzgerald, Terran Mazza, Joe Rosenberg, Vivian Lee, and feels like there's someone else. Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7KLW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row in BDOC. That's beautiful downtown Oakland, California. Yeah, I'm trying to make it a thing. 99% Invisible is a member of Radio Topia from PRX, an independent collective of the most innovative shows in all of podcasting. It's true.
团队其他成员包括艾弗里·特鲁夫曼、埃默特·菲茨杰拉德、泰兰·马扎、乔·罗森伯格、维维安·李，感觉还有另一个人。罗曼·马尔斯。我们是旧金山 91.7 KLW 的一个项目，在 BDOC 的 Radio Row 制作。那是加利福尼亚州美丽市中心奥克兰。是的，我正试图让它成为一个梗。《99% Invisible》是来自 PRX 的 Radiotopia 的成员，这是一个由播客界最具创新性的节目组成的独立集体。确实如此。
You can find the show and join the discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Katie Mingle. The show is at 99PI org. I'm going to be You can find the show and join the discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Katie Mingle. The show is at 99PI org. We're on Instagram, Tumblr, and Reddit too. But if you want to see the amazing Papino Power Authority logo, yes, it involves a cucumber with a hard hat on. Or if you want to print out a picture of St. Beard, put on your altar next time the power goes out, you'll find all of that and more at 99pi.org.
你可以在 Facebook 上找到本节目并参与讨论。你也可以在推特上@我 Katie Mingle。本节目的网址是 99PI.org。我们也在 Instagram、Tumblr 和 Reddit 上。但如果你想看神奇的帕皮诺电力局标志，是的，它包含一个戴着安全帽的黄瓜。或者如果你想打印一张圣胡子的照片，在下次停电时放在你的祭坛上，你会在 99pi.org 上找到所有这些以及更多内容。
Roman will be back next week. Radio til P.I. from PRX. from PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
罗曼下周将回归。来自 PRX 的 Radio 99% Invisible。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。